they've got you at the bottom of the
list which indicates to you that it's
probably going to get cut it sucks that
they don't get it they don't believe in
it yeah or or yeah I'm thinking they
they're not knowing what how physical
this is and you know I I'm like I'm
going to have to I'm G to have to do it
I'm G to have to show them and
I'm going have got to blow the roof off
the house you know so I did that dress
rehearsal and I was like my heart was
pounding and I remember it's like five
four three two and I went on there and I
just had to show them and I did it and I
you know had the skirt and I lifted my
leg up and I did gymnastics and I sang
and I did a monologue and I threw myself
into those chairs and flew and it killed
and then I went into Lauren Michael's
office between dress and airs all the
cast goes in you go in and look at his
bulletin board to see what's making it
to the live show and my sketch Mary
Catherine Gallagher got moved from the
bottom of the show to the top and I was
like yes oh wow